more concerns from specialists about the
hybrid learning transition plan
the clark county school district
released the updated 235 page guide just
yesterday brian 8 newshour reporter
kristen drummond shows us the issues
when pre-k
to third grade goes back to the
classroom on the first of march
all elementary students will have access
to specials each day
those classes include art music library
physical education and
humanities but some specialists question
their safety and responsibilities when
back in buildings i think this is a
logistical nightmare rachel frederick
teaches humanities at decker elementary
school
her lessons focus on computer science
but she wonders about her position
when hybrid learning begins march 1st
it's confusing like nobody can really
make sense of that chart
this page in the guide highlights
specialist jobs it says
they'll be assigned one classroom per
grade level to provide instruction
aligned with their specific assignment
meaning the likelihood of visiting
multiple classrooms to teach
there's just an equity issue the clark
county education association notices the
concern and tells me
the teachers union is working on an
agreement with ccsd specific to
specialists
a statement says in part under the
hybrid plan they will be exposed to
multiple students in more than one
classroom
we are asked to be seeing more
students than any other certified
teacher the expectation not only
includes teaching
live in a class but live streaming the
lesson to other classrooms in the grade
level
and to those participating in distance
education it's going to be really
challenging like how do you give that
individual attention
but the biggest frustration for
librarian nikki beilina streets and her
colleagues
being required to supervise classes
during teachers prep
time we're in essence being asked to
babysit
students adjustments when transitioning
from home to campus
kristin drummond 8 news now